Prof: So I wanted to
continue talking about air
quality today and air quality
law.
And also to make some comments
about Whitman v.
American Trucker in
response to a couple of
questions.
So with respect to
Whitman,
EPA in 1997 had proposed new PM
and ozone standards.
And both the Northeastern
states and California supported
these measures.
And members of Congress from
the Midwestern states did not
support it.
This is quite common with air
quality standards.
It was unprecedented in EPA's
history for a single change in a
national ambient air quality
standard to have twenty-eight
days of hearings in Congress.
And finally,
this was brought to court and
made its way to the Court of
Appeals in the D.C.
Circuit.
And the Circuit found that the
standards were unconstitutional.
It was eventually elevated up
to the Supreme Court,
and I read you the conclusion
of the Supreme Court.
But they also raised a separate
question about the consideration
of costs and whether or not
costs should be part of the
calculus.
In "Section 109(b)(1)
instructs the EPA to set primary
ambient air quality standards,
the attainment and maintenance
of which are requisite to
protect public health with an
adequate margin of safety."
That seems rather clear.
However, they went on,
saying that "the
respondents argue that many more
factors than air pollution
affect public health...In
particular,
the economic costs of
implementing a very stringent
standard might produce health
losses sufficient to offset the
health gains achieved in
cleaning the air,
for example,
by closing down whole
industries and thereby
impoverishing the workers and
consumers dependent upon those
industries."
So this is unquestionably true,
and the Congress was
unquestionably aware of it at
the time.
In considering the role of
economics in decision-making and
how that might be balanced
against estimates of risk and
the benefits from tougher air
quality regulations,
the court continued
"Congress had commissioned
in the Air Quality Act of 1967 a
detailed estimate of the
economic impact of air quality
standards on the nation's
industries,
communities,
and other contributing sources
of pollution...The 1970 Congress
not only anticipated the
compliance costs that could
injure the public health,
but provided for that precise
exigency."
And Section 110 of the Clean
Air Act permitted the
administrator to waive the
compliance deadline for
stationary sources if sufficient
control measures were simply
unavailable and "the
continued operation of such
sources was found to be
essential to the public health
or welfare."
And Section 202 prescribed that
emissions standards for
automobiles could take effect
only "after such a period
that the administrator finds
necessary to permit the
development and application of
the requisite technology,
giving appropriate
consideration to the cost of
compliance within such
period."
So EPA could decide that it's
time for a new air quality
standard,
but they could find that the
economic effects were so intense
that they could delay that and
offer the industry the
opportunity to retool or
reorganize in order to develop
the necessary technology,
say a new emission control
system in order to meet that new
standard.
So despite this consideration
of cost, the court found that
the engine driving nearly all of
Title I is Section 109(b)(1).
And I commend you to read this,
you can call it up on EPA's
website,
that these standards have to be
set to protect public health
with this margin of safety to
account for uncertainty in the
risk estimate.
So when in interpreting the
statutory text,
Congress does not,
one might say,
hide elephants in mouse holes.
So they overturned the
appellate ruling.
I want to take you back to
where I left you on Tuesday and
talk a little bit more about
asthma and the prevalence of
asthma and the finding by Mark
Cullen and Eileen Storey at the
University of Connecticut that
between three and twenty-two
percent of kids in Connecticut
schools have been diagnosed by
physicians.
And by the way,
one of the gold standards for
recognizing an illness in a
population would be looking at
whether or not it had been
diagnosed by a physician.
And in schools,
it's interesting that if your
child is on any medication,
then you have to register those
medications with the school
nurse.
So the school nurse has to keep
very tight control.
In fact, they maintain the meds
in the nurses' offices so that
this is a really interesting and
important and high quality
method of record keeping.
So Mark and I and several
others wondered together about
what the causes of the rise in
asthma might have been during
the 1980s and 1990s.
And we started thinking about
what had changed,
whether or not kids might be
exposed to different kinds of
chemicals.
And I left you also with this
lung section.
And I wanted to come back to
this, because I didn't explain
it very carefully the other day.
So on the left is basically rat
lung tissue exposed to low
concentrations of diesel
exhaust.
And what you see is the
coagulation between cells of the
particulate matter,
the carbon in those that are
exposed at higher
concentrations.
Now what this suggests is that
you might think about scenarios
that would lead to higher levels
of exposure.
So what might those be?
Well, we're talking about black
carbon in this case.
So when are people more exposed
to combustion byproducts?
So one of the things you should
always think about in terms of
those that are more exposed
would be occupational settings.
So how about,
for example,
miners?
So in coal mines,
the coal dust is also carbon
dust.
But also, they use diesel
generators to provide
electricity to basically give
energy to the jackhammers and to
the lighting that they have in
the mines.
So the combination of
unventilated diesel generator
fumes on top of the coal dust
leads to high exposures.
And what about truck drivers?
It was interesting,
after the study that I'm going
to review with you in a few
moments,
I received a phone call from
someone who had seen it,
and they wondered whether or
not they should get involved.
This was the American
Federation of Labor,
the AFL-CIO.
They were concerned that they
were an organization or truck
drivers that really might be one
of the more highly exposed
groups.
Highly exposed because they sit
inside their trucks all day
long,
and especially in urban areas
where traffic comes to a
standstill,
you could expect that the
exposures would be highest.
So occupational settings are
clearly one area where people
might be more heavily exposed.
A couple other human lung
tissue samples that I wanted to
show you with respect to black
carbon, actually,
only one.
So bringing you back to the map
and the concept of the way that
we understand the air pollution
problem is really driven by
these dots on this map.
Could be in any state in the
nation and you'd see a similar
kind of map with the monitoring
stations scattered about.
And in some instances,
they have a concentration where
they think that the ambient
concentrations are highest so
that you can see them down along
the southeastern part of the
coast.
And this is the area that is
out of compliance.
It's a "nonattainment
zone" for both particulate
matter and ozone.
And also, up in the Hartford
area so that you see a
collection of monitors.
But also, they are trying to
figure out the variability in
distribution of pollution,
so they put monitors also in
parts of the state that are less
densely populated.
So thinking about this,
a group of us decided that we
really wanted to understand what
the air was like in the kids'
day.
So rather than relying on the
reports from these different
monitoring stations,
what if we took monitors and we
put them on children and then we
followed them through their
daily routine,
from the time they left home to
the time that they came back to
their house after school?
So a group of us,
including David Brown from the
Centers for Disease Control and
Nancy Alderman,
who runs a group called
Environment and Human Health,
Mark Cullen,
Susan Addis,
the former Commissioner of
Health in Connecticut,
and Bob LaCamera,
who is a professor of
pediatrics here.
This was the group that took
this study on,
along with some technical
analysts at UConn that run the
EPA testing lab.
So all of the air quality
measurements that are taken in
the state go through their
laboratory to make sure that
they're carefully analyzed.
And I also left you with this
chart so that you could keep in
mind the idea that you've got a
temporal variation in ambient
outdoor air quality that appears
to be driven and perhaps
predictable,
not just by month of the year,
but also by hour of the day.
So what were these monitors
like?
Here's an example.
A gas canister,
a little metal globe that was
pulling in air at a preset rate,
it had a vacuum in it.
So that we were looking for
about fifty-five different
volatile organic compounds that
we knew were part of diesel
emissions.
And by the way,
we weren't really sure whether
or not the exposure was highest
during the travel to school or
whether or not their exposure
and their risk would be highest
within the school.
So we used a variety of
different pieces of equipment
that could monitor chemicals
that might be more concentrated
either in traffic or in indoor
environments.
In indoor environments,
what kinds of chemicals might
you be concerned about?
Well, it could be,
say, the chemicals in a
photography laboratory or a
chemistry laboratory,
such as benzene or other
solvents.
Or it might be other kinds of
cleaning products,
or it could be pesticides.
So that we tried to figure this
out in a way that would point us
to the most risky sources of
exposure.
And with respect to particulate
matter, these carbon particles,
this was the chart that we
produced.
By the way, part of the story
is that this is my daughter when
she was about twelve years old.
So she was the first guinea pig.
She agreed to carry this BOC
canister, but also she has a
formaldehyde pump sitting here
on her jacket.
And she's got a particle meter
here to strapped to her belt.
And she carried an IV cart that
had a carbon monitor,
an ethylometer that's about the
size of a microwave.
So she walked around with this
thing by her side all day long.
And as a rather amusing
anecdote on the side,
when she first stepped on a
bus, all the kids in the back of
the bus screamed because of our
post-eleven sensitivity about
what people might look like all
strapped up in technical
equipment.
The bus driver threw her off
the bus.
And that's when I realized that
I should have called the
superintendent and warned them
what we were doing.
So here's the outcome of our
initial tests.
We found that there was a burst
of exposure early in the day to
PM 10, and also a burst of
exposure at the end of the day.
But there were also increases
that we saw during the middle of
the day that really were not
explained.
And it took us a little while
to figure it out,
but the kind of particles that
we were measuring varied by
where the child was.
So if they're waiting for the
bus or they're on the school
bus, one could presume that
these were carbon particles.
But if they're just in the gym
moving around,
these could be dust particles.
So if I had a chalkboard up
here and I could take an eraser
and just pat it against the
board,
you'd see a cloud of PM 10,
particulate matter ten,
move up into the air.
The same thing with a gymnasium
where you have say fifty kids
running around playing
basketball or some other sport.
You get particles moving into
the air.
So we needed to discern the
carbon particles from other
kinds of particles.
So 600,000 school buses exist
in the United States,
and we also faced the problem
of trying to figure out whether
or not exposure during those
high periods early in the day
and late in the day were the
result of going to school in
traffic from the buses or were
the particles coming from other
vehicles?
So I'll tell you a bit more
about that in just a moment.
So here's a very quick summary
of this study that was picked up
by Good Morning,
America when it was
released.
GMA Host:
But now we turn back to this
story.
Important news for every parent
of children who ride school
buses.
Later today,
a new study from Yale
University will be released,
saying the amount of diesel
fumes emitted by most school
buses reaches levels that are
substantially higher than the
government standard.
And those fumes are going
directly into the air your
children breathe.
Our consumer correspondent Greg
Hunter has an exclusive look at
the study.
Greg Hunter [on video]:
Twenty-four million
children in America ride to and
from school every day on a fleet
of nearly 600,000 school buses.
Most are powered by diesel fuel.
And each of those children,
on average, spends an estimated
180 hours every year on board
one of those buses.
Here's the bad news.
According to a new Yale
University study by Professor
John Wargo, some kids are
getting high levels of diesel
exhaust from their school bus.
Using ultra-sensitive monitors,
which he placed directly on
school children,
Wargo took readings of the air
quality around the children
every minute throughout the
entire school day.
So you found out exactly what
they were breathing in,
minute to minute?
John Wargo [on video]:
Yeah, we mapped it out.
Actually, every ten seconds we
took a reading.
Greg Hunter [on video]:
Wargo's readings showed
spikes in the measurement of
diesel exhaust at certain points
of the day.
His results differ from those
of the EPA because the EPA
measures air quality at fixed
locations and averages the
results over a three-year
period.
How much higher than the
government's acceptable level
were you finding routinely?
John Wargo [on video]:
Well,
for short periods of time,
we were finding levels that
were five to 10 times higher
than the government standard.
Greg Hunter [on video]:
That's a big spike.
John Wargo [on video]:
It was a surprise to me.
Greg Hunter [on video]:
There's no telling exactly
what exposure to this kind of
diesel exhaust could do to a
child's health,
but children with asthma,
like thirteen-year-old Erin
Paternoster,
say they feel it every time
they get on the bus.
Did you ever have a time when
you got on the bus feeling great
and got off the bus feeling
sick?
Erin Paternoster [on video]:
Yeah, many times,
I go on the bus and then I come
off of it and I feel tightness
in my chest or I can feel like
I'm starting to wheeze or I feel
like I need my inhaler.
Greg Hunter [on video]:
Her father,
John, is outraged.
John Paternoster [on video]:
I'm not sure you're going
to find a parent who's going to
say,
you know, we're--we're doing
something right now that's
harmful to our children,
let's wait five more years
before we do anything about it.
Parents won't stand for that.
Greg Hunter [on video]:
But that's exactly what
the EPA is doing.
In 2006, they're going to
implement new,
cleaner standards for all
diesel engines,
including school buses.
The reason they're implementing
cleaner standards,
in part, they say,
because diesel exhaust is
likely to cause lung cancer,
and they say the regulations
will prevent more than 8,000
premature deaths and more than
300,000 asthma attacks.
Wargo used two devices,
one measured gases like benzene
and the other measured
ultra-fine particles such as
soot.
Wargo had 15 school children
carry these devices throughout
their school day.
John Wargo [on video]:
What we found was in the
morning, when they got on the
bus, they were exposed to a high
intensity of particulates.
They tended to diminish during
the school day.
And then at the end of the day,
there was another burst to
their exposure.
Greg Hunter [on video]:
Wargo also found the level
of diesel exhaust aboard the
buses was especially high under
certain conditions,
such as when the buses were
parked end to end in front of
the school,
with the engines idling.
I can smell the exhaust on the
bus.
John Wargo [on video]:
Yes, absolutely.
Greg Hunter [on video]:
So it comes right out--
The school bus industry says
there's an earlier study
conducted in a Virginia school
district last March that shows
breathing the air on Fairfax
County Public Schools' buses
poses no health risks.
GMA Interviewee:
Obviously,
one thing is caution the
parents of the country,
don't be alarmed at this point.
Let's wait and make sure we
understand everything before we
make decisions that affect the
health of our children and our
own health ourselves.
Greg Hunter [on video]:
Another industry group,
the Diesel Technology Forum,
argues that the diesel engines
now being produced are much
cleaner than the diesel engines
of the past,
and that with proper
maintenance, diesel school buses
pose no threat to riders.
The costly process of upgrading
a large bus fleet still poses a
challenge to cash-strapped
public schools,
and even with the cash,
it will still take time.
Diane Sawyer [on video]:
Our consumer correspondent
Greg Hunter joins us now.
So you're a parent,
you see this,
you want to do something,
what?
Greg Hunter [on video]:
One of the best things Dr.
Wargo says that schools can do,
and they do it in California
and they do it in states like
Connecticut, is having a no-idle
policy.
The school bus pulls up,
they cut the engine off and
that way they're not kicking out
all that diesel exhaust.
Another thing they can do is
stagger the times for the buses
to come in,
so instead of all of them
pulling up,
the kids getting on,
and all of them pulling off,
they stagger the times they
come in and that will help
alleviate the problem.
He says it's going to be kind
of expensive retrofitting some
of these buses,
five to $6,000,
it's going to take time.
Diane Sawyer [on video]:
What's more important?
Prof: Okay.
A couple of asides.
When we were both standing on
the school bus,
there was a film crew there
with about six people.
The fumes were-- it was a day
actually like this,
with a high level of humidity.
All of us got sick.
All of us got sick within a
matter of about five minutes.
And it was curious,
because the consumer
correspondent,
Greg Hunter,
he didn't believe that we were
really picking up chemicals that
were dangers.
But after he and the entire
crew felt nauseous and we all
got headaches because we had
lined the buses up one in front
of another,
and we the emissions were
basically just building up as
the time went by.
He was clearly convinced that
this was a more serious problem.
So I want to take you back to
the averaging issue,
and remember that there's
twenty-four-hour averaging
requirement over three years
that's in play with this
standard.
And that was represented by the
graph that I showed you
yesterday.
If you took the data that we
produced for just one child,
as an example,
and you average it over one
hour or over eight hours,
you see that all of the levels
would be reduced.
So your image of what the
levels were would be down in
this low range,
missing experiences of much
higher pollution.
So again, the averaging issue
played out in the way that we
had to think about different
kinds of strategies.
The other issue that I wanted
to bring to your attention that
surprised me was that the amount
of time,
the amount of exposure,
was far higher than I could
have imaged.
So this diagram just shows you
that the millions of hours per
year spent on buses by kids in
different states.
And I want to point to just a
couple of states here.
New York has the highest amount
of time spent by child hours on
a bus,
predominately because of the
rural parts of New York and the
relatively high population in
New York.
But compare that to California.
California has a little bit
less than half of the hours or
the total exposure than New
York.
Now why might that be?
Anybody have an idea?
Sorry?
Student: **
Prof: Okay,
well remember the population of
California is 40 million people,
so it's a much larger
population than New York.
And I think that the answer is
likely to be the way that
residential population and
communities in California are
more closely clustered together
than they are in New York state.
So also, what we found that in
places like Idaho,
Wyoming, and Alaska that it's
very common for kids to spend
two,
three, hours a day on buses,
as opposed to here in
Connecticut,
maybe an hour at most,
forty-five minutes to an hour.
So the pattern of land use
really was driving the pattern
of exposure that varied quite a
bit state by state.
And one other aspect of this
that was important was that kids
that have disabilities,
and they might be disabled for
a whole array of different
reasons,
but kids that are disabled are
often bussed to regional
districts,
regional school systems,
that have very specialized
expertise.
So on average,
kids with disabilities that are
moved around to benefit from the
specialized expertise,
they experience a higher level
of exposure.
Some kids spend three or four
hours per day going back and
forth between these control
centers.
And I mentioned earlier in the
term that I got a call from a
woman in Alaska who wondered
about her child who was only
three years old who she put just
behind the driver's seat.
She was the driver of the bus.
The child was asthmatic,
and she was having trouble
controlling the asthma with
medications.
And she wondered whether or not
the school bus might be a
problem.
So I asked her,
"Well, how long is your
daily routine?
How long does your child spend
on the bus?"
And it was eight and a half
hours per day.
So that thinking about these
high-end exposures and which
groups in the population might
be susceptible is an important
aspect of this.
So just one other thing that
was interesting in terms of
study design.
And again, in terms of sampling
strategy, first of all,
we were monitoring individual
kids and individual buses.
And I just want to reinforce
again the importance of thinking
about sampling strategy,
and remember the little
200-mile radius from the Nevada
test site when the Atomic Energy
Commission set up their sampling
design in that way,
and how everybody was fooled
into thinking that those
particles wouldn't go beyond
that area.
There's another defect in
scientific thinking that led to
confusion.
In this case,
we really didn't understand
whether or not the level of
pollution that we were measuring
was coming from inside the bus,
from other traffic,
or from other sources.
And recall the other day I said
within Connecticut we burn three
times as much diesel fuel
indoors to heat our buildings
compared to what's emitted from
vehicles.
So it was very important to us
to get a sense of what was
actually coming out of a bus.
So we set up a separate
experimental bus route in a very
rural part of Connecticut that
was far away from any
residential unit or any other
source of carbon that we could
think of other than carbon
that's kind of moving long
distance and existing at low
levels.
So we would look at our meters
and see that the levels were
close to zero,
and this was reflected also in
the state's monitoring
facilities.
And then we turned the buses on.
And we saw an immediate jump in
the particulate count and also
in the BOC emissions within the
buses after we did that.
We also saw a couple of
interesting patterns.
And my daughter,
for example,
was on a school bus.
She was picked up near my house
and she was taken to school.
And there's this increase in
concentration,
which is kind of curious.
And then as she got to a school
where she got off the bus for
about ten minutes or five
minutes until she was
transferred to another bus.
She walked about fifty yards
away from the bus and then got
back on the next bus and it
picked her up and took her
eventually to school.
So this was a pretty good
demonstration that the air
quality within the bus itself
was a serious source of
exposure.
We also found kind of curiously
if we looked at kind of the
horizontal movement and we also
looked at the behavioral pattern
that we could figure out that
elevation change across a route
made a difference in the
particle level within the bus
cabin.
So as a bus went uphill,
it's under load,
it produces more pollution,
emissions are quite a bit
higher both for BOCs as well as
for the small particles.
In fact, I was coming to work
the other day in traffic,
and there was a truck next to
me and the truck was using his
engine as a brake.
So we would accelerate in
traffic, and I was right behind
this bus,
accelerate in traffic,
I could see the dark black
smoke coming out,
meaning the engine is under
load and it's not operating very
efficiently.
And then the traffic in front
of the truck would slow down and
he would use his engine to brake
the truck.
It was under load again,
and then you see the black
smoke come up again.
So remember that a cruising
speed at about sixty-five,
seventy miles an hour is the
most efficient level of
combustion for most diesel
trucks and vehicles.
And by the way,
I don't think I mentioned this
the other day,
there are about 90 million
diesel trucks and vehicles in
the United States today.
So this problem is much bigger
than just the 600,000 school
buses that I'm looking at in
this study.
We also found that if we
compared the level of exposure
to the kids on the bus inside
the cabin to the federal
standard,
that they were experiencing
levels that were quite a bit
higher,
sometimes twenty to twenty-five
times higher for short periods
of time.
And then we found this kind of
a curious thing,
that an idling vehicle collects
more pollution inside the cabin
than a moving vehicle.
So there's a ventilation
process that occurs when a
vehicle moves,
unless the vehicle is moving in
a train of buses that are coming
into a school or leaving a
school.
By the way, most vehicles have
no filtration system.
Most trucks and buses have no
filtration system for the air in
the indoor cabin.
And by the way,
if you get to the point where
you want to buy a new car,
I would really encourage you to
think carefully about the
relative quality of air
filtration.
There are some vehicles now,
the Japanese vehicles started
to put filtration equipment in
first,
but it makes a significant
difference to the quality of the
indoor air.
You can test that in a kind of
an interesting way with respect
to particulates and carbon.
You can just take your finger,
don't clean your dashboard for
six months for example,
and then just take your finger
and wipe it across and you'll
pick up a variety of particles
that will come in because the
interior cabin is so poorly
filtered.
So this idling issue prompted
us to think well one no brainer
as a policy response would be to
try to get the bus drivers to
shut their engines off while
they were idling.
This was a much harder problem
to crack with respect to trucks.
Because trucks today are
commonly on,
their ignition is switched on
twenty-four hours a day because
the engine itself is providing
electricity through a generator
to refrigerate the cargo.
But it's also providing
electricity for the main cabin.
And for some long-distance
haulers, especially independent
operators, they basically live
in their trucks.
They will pull over to the side
of a McDonald's and sleep for
six or eight hours.
Or they'll pull into a trucks
stop,
and most truck stops are not
equipped with these electronic
outlets so that they could plug
their truck in and turn their
engine off.
So they're burning fuel almost
twenty-four hours and idling.
And the level of emissions are
higher in the engine while it's
idling.
But also, I think that the
truck drivers' exposure is
really quite a serious issue.
So we also found that the
filtration equipment in these
buses that were built in year
2000 was so poor,
it virtually was large enough,
the little spaces in the air
filter were large enough so that
you could stick a pencil point
through it.
So clearly, it wasn't going to
give any protection at all for
low-diameter particular matter,
PM 10 or PM 2.5.
So there are a variety of
factors here that you can read
that influence the degree of
concentration.
Whether or not the windows or
open or whether or not they're
closed,
the engine type,
the age of the engine in the
bus,
so that older buses are more
polluting than newer buses are.
And one curious thing about
this was whenever I do a study,
I always assume that I'm going
to get sued.
And I was assuming that the
large diesel manufacturing
companies were going to give me
a pretty rough ride.
And I was really quite
surprised, because they wanted
to promote my work.
They were really interested in
having this become very common
knowledge.
And why might that be?
Student: Sell new
engines.
Prof: Sorry?
Student: Sell new
engines.
Prof: Sell new engines,
that's exactly the answer.
They were interested in selling
new engines that would emit
lower levels of the particles
that we were measuring.
And put that idea together with
the fact that most trucks have
an active lifespan of three to
four million miles and often
thirty to sometimes even
thirty-five years.
So they were anxious that the
standards be lowered so that
they could sell more vehicles.
So there are a variety of
lessons here.
We were also measuring
emissions when the vehicles were
using a sulfur content in the
fuel that was 500 parts per
million.
And remember I told you the
other day that now the ultra-low
sulfur fuels are available and
in use as a requirement,
completely phased in in the
nation as well as particle traps
that will take out some of the
compounds of concern.
Now as you're thinking about
this as a policy problem and
you're thinking about it with
respect to the Clean Air Act,
you should also think about
different parts of the country
that are either within or out of
compliance with air standards.
So these exposures that are
being experienced by kids or the
drivers, they're coming on top
of background air quality
problems.
In other words,
if you look here in
Connecticut,
you see that we are,
the southern part of
Connecticut,
we are in an orange,
where we're exceeding the
eight-hour ozone standard.
And we were also,
when we were doing the study,
exceeding the particulate
matter standard as well.
So that on a day like this,
you get many of the particles
being rained out of the air.
But on a still,
humid day in the middle of the
summer, you're going to get a
very high level background
ambient-- it's called ambient
exposure.
So that these within-the-bus
exposures or,
you can imagine other kinds of
pollutants in your daily life,
are coming on top of this
background level of exposure.
I was also quite surprised to
find that diesel particles are
measurable in any building in
the nation.
There's an ambient background
of diesel particles even in this
room as we were able to discern
just the other day.
But I can't smell diesel
exhaust in the room today,
but if you had the latest and
most sensitive detection
equipment, you could smell it.
So we're all experiencing this
background level of exposure.
So one way of thinking about it
is how many hours on the bus is
going to lead to what kind of a
total exposure?
And so if the blue here is
representative of the background
level of exposure,
maybe seventeen,
eighteen micrograms per cubic
meter of PM 2.5,
then these other bus exposures
in the colored segments are
coming on top of that.
So if you look way over on the
right,
for a child that's on a bus for
three hours,
they would be experiencing the
level of pollution that would be
twice what the federal standard
is.
So as you're thinking about how
to create a health-protective
standard,
you need to think about these
ambient average background
levels that are being picked up
and measured by the fixed
monitoring equipment.
But also think about just how
daily behavior leads people to
be exposed in very different
ways.
Now, also, it's curious that
the European Union is moving
much more rapidly to promote
diesel vehicles and diesel
engines,
predominately to reduce
CO_2 emissions.
So that diesel now represents
about twenty percent of the
Europeans' passenger fleet,
whereas in the United States,
it represents less than three
percent.
So that it presents a real
dilemma to think through do we
want to reduce CO_2 or
do we want to be more concerned
about lowering the level of
exposure to these particulates?
So these kinds of questions can
lead to policy recommendations.
And for any kind of a problem,
I want to encourage you to
think about first of all,
what's the right target for
your proposal?
Is it the federal government,
state government,
local governments?
Would it be voluntary standards
that you might encourage to the
corporations that manufacture
these products?
Or what could you recommend to
an individual to reduce their
exposure today?
Kind of curiously,
in response to that last
question,
many parents responded to this
study that got much more
publicity than it deserved in
terms of the investment in
money.
This study cost about probably
30 to $35,000 to do.
But people all over the country
stopped driving their kids to
school, which was a problem.
So I had to come up with some
press releases that demonstrated
that congestion at some schools
was increasing because people
were not putting their kids on
the bus.
And it was also increasing the
risk of injury from accidents at
the schools.
So that driving your kids to
school is not the right answer.
You get many more vehicles
arriving at the school,
creating pollution that would
be higher than what would be
coming from the bus.
So recommendations to the
federal government,
retrofit diesel buses to ensure
lower emissions.
Put particle traps on them.
And as the film segment showed,
that's expensive.
That costs about $6,000 per
vehicle to do.
And it's an important issue.
And some of the states and the
federal government have really
stepped up in response to this.
So who's going to pay for this?
Well, it's interesting that so
far,
I've been keeping track of what
the state expenditures have been
and what the federal
government's expenditures have
been.
And right now,
we're close to a half a billion
dollars that's been spent on
school bus retrofits or
substituting the lower emitting,
newer engines for the older
engines.
So that requiring the buses to
use ultra-low sulfur fuel at the
time the study came out was a
really important recommendation.
Five hundred parts per million
of sulfur as opposed to fifteen
parts per million of sulfur
produces a much,
much higher level of
particulate matter.
So testing tailpipe emissions,
it's kind of interesting that
we have to have our cars tested
for tailpipe emissions,
but trucks and buses generally
do not.
So that they are exempt.
In fact, they can be pulled
over on the highway and they can
be asked by a Department of
Environmental Protection
employee working for the state
to turn their engine on,
and they will hold what's
called a Ringelmann Chart up
against it that gives them
different levels of opacity.
And they'll hold that up
against the sky and visually try
to compare the darkness of the
emissions to their chart to
figure out whether or not they
think that the truck is in
compliance.
Well, this is not the right way
to go.
There should be a much more
intense and precise estimate
that we have the technology
available to conduct those kinds
of emissions testing.
So the other thing to think
here that is important on this
list is that the federal
standards,
the fifteen micrograms per
cubic meter,
that is assuming a safe level,
what the safe threshold would
be with respect to outdoor
pollution,
not with respect to
within-vehicle pollution or
other indoor sources being added
on top of that.
So my belief is that these
federal standards are not health
protective because they
basically are looking at the
problem as one source at a time
or just measuring what's going
on in the outdoor environment
and forgetting that we spend
ninety percent of our time
either indoors or within
vehicles.
So we also clearly need to
expand the monitoring network.
And the idea that we're getting
our image of the intensity of
this kind of a problem by just
relying on fixed monitors
outdoors,
it really makes little sense.
So putting monitors on
individuals and then following
through their daily life,
that's going to give you a much
more accurate representation of
really what your exposure and
risk might be.
So this is a very expensive
alternative.
But it's likely to be the wave
of the future.
So a second target for this
study has been state
governments.
So what could state governments
do that the federal government
could not do?
Well, they could prohibit
school bus idling by statute.
And in fact,
when this study came out,
we proposed a law in
Connecticut that would demand a
maximum of three minutes for
idling.
And since we did that,
there are twenty-six other
states that have adopted this
same idea.
Save fuel as well as reduce
pollution.
So it's kind of a double-win
situation.
Also, requiring more buses to
drive shorter distances is
another way of reducing
exposure.
So when most school districts,
like we're seeing today with
respect to declining state
grants and federal grants to
school districts,
what are they doing?
They're using fewer buses and
they're putting the kids on the
buses for longer periods of
time.
So the routes are actually
going in the wrong direction,
leading to higher exposures.
And finally,
local governments are really
responsible for enforcing these
idling bans.
And we found in a couple of
follow-up studies that there's
about a fifty-five to
seventy-five percent compliance
rate for no idling,
particularly at schools.
When we did the study,
all the buses would pull up and
they'd idle while the kids got
on the buses or they would idle
as the kids got off the buses to
go into school.
But now, it's quite interesting.
The monitors here turned out
not to be people that worked for
the government,
but instead,
the school teachers.
Because the school teachers
have long been angry,
I hadn't understood this,
but they were angry at the way
that the emissions were making
their way into the school.
And we found that many school
systems had their ventilation
systems set up so that they were
pulling the air from the bus
loading area into the school.
And I had one superintendent
tell me that she always knew
when the buses were arriving,
even though she was 250 yards
away from where they were
arriving on the other side of
the complex because the air
ventilation system was picking
it up and redistributing it
throughout the entire school.
So just kind of thinking about
building design as well is
important.
Also, in my own town,
in response to this,
because we did some of the
testing in the town,
when the town built a new
school two years ago,
it decided to create a staging
area,
a separate parking facility
where buses could go.
And instead of all the buses
training in at the same time or
all leaving at the same time,
they could stagger it,
so that when one bus is
following another bus,
it's simply going to be picking
up the exhaust and distributing
it.
So I wanted to give you just a
sense of a couple of kind of air
quality problems that you may
not have heard of.
This one was new to me.
There was a CNN reporter whose
beat is the Pentagon who called
me the other day and he said,
"Can you help me out?
Can you help me understand what
the threat is to people in the
military from open-pit
burning?"
Open-pit burning of garbage
right now is prohibited in the
United States,
although many people do it in
their backyard.
And open-pit burning is the
primary source of emission of
dioxins to the atmosphere.
So people on the right-hand
side of this in a barrel will
stuff their garbage,
their waste,
into it and just burn it
instead of having to pay for a
trash collector.
So you might save a hundred
dollars per month if you did
this.
So that what's coming out is a
product of very low-temperature
combustion which is perfect for
the formation of dioxins and
furans.
And dioxins,
some of the congeners are known
to be the most carcinogenic
substances that we are now aware
of.
So that also you could think
about how pollution would kind
of gather on the surface nearby,
could gather on foods or
vegetable gardens,
but also kids playing in a
sandbox.
So this is kind of a surprising
source of our exposure to
dioxins that are persistent,
bioaccumulative,
and carcinogenic.
There is a lawsuit that is
being considered by a group of
those in the air force that were
responsible for maintaining
these trash pits.
They were responsible to throw
the garbage in.
And you can imagine what their
exposure would be.
And what is the primary
component now of most of our
waste?
Well, it's turning out to be,
in terms of spatial volume
rather than weight,
it's turning out to be
plastics.
So plastics when they're
burned, particularly polyvinyl
chloride, is pretty well
recognized to emit dioxins.
We have another phenomena going
on in response to higher fossil
fuel prices,
especially in the northern
latitudes in the country,
and these are would boilers.
People are buying wood boilers
and basically not using their
furnaces, their natural gas
furnaces or their diesel fuel
furnaces.
So that these burn at a fairly
low temperature and they also
emit a variety of pollutants,
including most of the particles
in diameters that are quite
small,
just like tobacco smoke or like
diesel emissions.
And here's just one example of
the effect of one household
having one wood burner.
And you can see this is
spreading over an area that is
now at this point in the
photograph, it's about almost a
half a mile wide.
And the concentration of
particulates in this area,
because I've worked on wood
smoke, if you can see wood smoke
at this level,
the particulate concentrations
are likely to be in the many
multiples above that fifteen
microgram federal limit.
So that this is a phenomenon
that is increasing in prevalence
and leading to really quite
extreme exposures.
I know this firsthand because I
have a neighbor that installed
one of these boilers.
And he lives in a valley and I
live on the hill above the
valley.
So every morning when the air
is still because the sun hasn't
energized the atmosphere,
it builds up in the valley,
just like you can see in this
case.
It takes the sun to heat the
atmosphere, and basically until
about nine or ten o'clock,
it elevates.
But our house is filled with
wood smoke from his house,
as an example.
And the compounds in wood smoke
are just as dangerous as the
compounds in tobacco.
You know, one other kind of
idea that a student picked up on
after this lecture a few years
ago was the idea of mapping out
healthy routes for exercise in
urban environments.
I mean, could you think about
what the healthiest route would
be through New Haven to ride
your bike or to run?
I mean, you certainly wouldn't
want to run,
say, in New York City within
Central Park,
where you would have much
higher air quality than you
would if you ran,
say along the Hudson River
Parkway.
So could you map out the
healthiest running route?
And the student did,
putting our particle meters on
a bicycle.
And one other thing that I'd
like you to think about that
we're not going to have much
time to consider is the kinds of
consumer behaviors that can lead
to rather intense exposures.
Whether or not it's the plug-in
fragrances, the car air
fresheners, and when I saw this,
I mean, everybody knows about
these.
But the concept that you're
sitting in traffic and you're
really bothered by diesel
exhaust so you put up a car air
freshener that's emitting
volatile organic compounds that
you may think are more pleasing
than the diesel exhaust,
but they are largely untested,
they're completely unregulated.
Also, the idea of aromatherapy,
not knowing what those
compounds are.
Fragrances, when we talk about
plastics next week,
we'll find that there are
plasticizers that are hormonally
active in humans and many
species of mammals that are
components of some of the most
heavily-used fragrances.
And also, laundry detergents.
And many people are
experiencing reactions to these
fragrances.
And we're getting them in
mixtures that really are not
well understood.
So I'll leave you with that,
thinking that as you walk
through your daily life,
think about ways you could
modify your behavior in a way
that would reduce your exposure.
Thank you very much.